new information on the scope of the
durham probe sources telling fox news
that special counsel john durham is done
investigating the cia's role in the
origins of the russia probe
durham has reportedly moved his focus to
the fbi but sources are also saying it's
unlikely that high-ranking officials
like jim comey
will be charged joining me now former
director of national intelligence former
united states congressman former u.s
attorney john ratcliffe john how are you
trey great to be with you thank you
i want to begin by taking a look back uh
jim comey back in
2018 uh listen to this and we'll get
your thoughts on the other side
a total confidence that the fisa process
was
followed and that the entire case was
handled in a thoughtful responsible way
by doj
and the fbi i think the notion that
pfizer was abused here is
nonsense nonsense
i think you were one of the republicans
on the other side of that wall
asking him questions so let let me first
ask you do you expect more indictments
from the durham probe
i think the the intelligence that i've
seen would uh reflect
uh that there would be additional
actions taken by john durham
um you know i that clip that you played
there clip uh trey i remember it well
you and i did
uh ask a lot of questions because we
were convinced that there was fisa abuse
um and we were unfortunately right and
jim comey had to walk that back and we
saw the lawyer that
created those false applications plead
guilty this week
and it's for that same reason that when
i became dni and i saw more intelligence
i became more convinced that there were
more incidents
like that as it related to the 2016
campaign
without betraying any confidence as i
can tell you i sat in a room
last july with john durham and with
attorney general barr and we looked at
intelligence and we all
unanimously agreed that there was a
problem there with respect to the fbi
that there wasn't a proper predicate to
begin
much less continue a counterintelligence
investigation
against the trump campaign so i'd be
surprised if this reporting is accurate
that there aren't going to be additional
indictments i would expect that i think
the intelligence
that i've seen reflects that
and i certainly think that you know once
the investigation runs its course
that that's what will take place
you know johnny i was struck with a with
a dichotomy you've got jim comey out
there saying what
you and other house republicans were
doing looking into fisa abuse was
nonsense and you have this sycophantish
mob of reporters around him
i wonder if the kleinsmith plea changed
his mind at all
since now more fbi employees have been
to prison than members of the trunk
family
i i don't know you know we i would hope
so
but you know i hope that where this
investigation goes is that
uh that there are additional folks held
accountable not because i want to see
folks go to prison but because i want
people to have faith and trust in the
fbi and the department of justice
and increasingly they don't um you know
the american people have seen the text
messages and the emails
and the memos and the transcripts um
and the fisa applications and they know
this just isn't right and you know you
talked earlier
about fairness and they see that this
just wasn't fair
and if the fbi and the department of
justice can't hold folks accountable for
that
then we're going to have a problem down
the road
john i want to switch to another hat you
were a u.s attorney but you're also the
director of national intelligence
democrats have criticized you
for your focus on china it seems like
maybe you wound up being right
well i increased the spending on china
by 20 percent because china's our
greatest national security threat i
think
increasingly you know you're seeing some
of the
biden administration officials talk
about the threat that china's
becoming and my point is this can we all
just be honest about china can we now
treat intelligence on china
the same way we would treat intelligence
on russia
take this for example if we had
intelligence clear intelligence that
said that vladimir putin
ordered scientists in saint petersburg
to
experiment on coronaviruses at the saint
petersburg institute of virology
and there was an accident or a problem
and people started getting sick
and putin ordered that st petersburg be
shut off from the rest of
russia but opened to the rest of the
world and he silenced
scientists and doctors and reporters
that wanted to talk about it and he lied
to the world health organization and as
a result of that 400
000 americans died as a direct result of
that virus
what do you think uh the biden
administration and democrats and the
media would be
saying about russia um let's be honest
and because that's exactly what the
intelligence shows us china did in this
case
and it's why china is our greatest
national security threat
and why we have to be clear-eyed about
it going forward
well johnny i don't have to wonder what
one house democrat
would say about that because he said
that you were
kind of falsely equating china with
russia i think it was an old colleague
of yours named derek swalwall
we may have this clip if you want to
listen to it again if it brings back
good memories
the president's administration put out a
statement that you have
china and russia and iran and they're
all interfering
and give and gave this false equivalence
to them
what is accurate uh is in the statement
that was put out today is russia
continues to interfere in our elections
the way the administration is proceeding
is to just say well
everyone is interfering
well i i thought i showed a good bit of
restraint
when congressman swalwell was
criticizing me about that
because i knew what the public didn't
know at that point in time about
um you know his relationship well you
don't have to show restraint now
just be yourself you don't have to show
restraint anymore just be yourself
well my point is uh what's important
is that the intelligence community be
honest about china and that
people stop trying to politicize
intelligence to make
china less of a threat or russia more of
a threat
let the intelligence speak for itself
and if it does we'll realize that china
and china alone is the greatest
national security threat the one country
that can supplant the united states is
the world superpower
and i want the biden administration to
be honest about that because
if they don't recognize that we're all
going to suffer so hopefully
everyone will not just agree that i was
right about china
but that we'll be honest about china
going forward
johnny we got about 30 seconds tough
question uh give me a give me a quick
answer
and from your time as the dni what
scares you
the most what do you know now that you
did not know
the day before you took the job and and
keeps you awake at night
well i think the three greatest threats
that we face i talk about china that's
why i increase spending by 20 percent
cyber security uh is the other great
threat it's a great equalizer where
countries like
china or russia or north korea or iran
that can't compete with us kinetically
can compete
and cause us damage from half a world
away in a few seconds and a few key
strokes
thank you johnny thank you for your
service to our country